davvero a tutti voi ragazzi e benvenuti
a questo nuovo episodio strategico di
oggi facciamo una partitella ma di
quelle proprio
allora cosa ma cosa marco così demonio
ma come ma no all'acqua ma quanto ci
mette sempre 8 ore a carica ma dai
granchi italia cioè non aspetta un
attimo ragazzi forse ce la faccio non
solo dietro porc all aperto o no non c'è
lavoro non c'è una boccata maggio per
uno l'ultimo ero l'ultimo no non ci
voglio credere
niente scherza po troppo topi all'acqua
ma evidentemente prossimo tra ci penso
sei volte fai prendere l'acqua mentre si
gioca puglisi cosa prima regola lo
scrivono proprio quando accetti 6 tutti
i contratti con volta che riguardi di un
gioco quindi di far accetta che tu non
legge mai c'è scritto mai andare a
prendere l'acqua c'è tutto quello che di
fidatevi è servito vai bene
meno male che ha per ora ha funzionato
allora dai no se vinco questa potrebbe
essere la miglior partita vinta che
sempre ovviamente difficilissimo
arrivare a dire ma [ __ ]
forse c'è forse ce la faccio ancora
norma che ho recuperato la prima in un
modo pazzesco se la perdo così niente e
quando quando perdi quando devi perdere
proprio scritto romanaccia o la notte
l'ho fatta pazzesco meno male anche
questa l'ho tirata l'ho fatta da schifo
ragazzi ma ve la prima la gara un cielo
questa compatta ma meno male tutte e due
per il rotto della cuffia pensa celine
costa partita che arriverà deve essere
un bel fourball ragazzi pensione non poi
non facciamo attenzione a va bene a
chiusi lei di mamma mia sono avvenuti 23
da una parte ragazzi tre dall'altra e ci
portiamo a casa la vittoria dai vabbè
non ha mai fatto prima io non me lo dà
siamo ultimi eccolo e non esco non esco
passarci la sopra e ciò anche provato
per fare le cose fatte bene ma non
riesco ragazzi prima e quello perché c'è
troppa gente madonna ma possibile bravo
zio spara quello lì a dove uscito era
già sopra quello match a lui doppio alla
uno l'ha data lui sporca vaccaro entrato
in due cerchi in uno no ragazzi la
nostra vincendo ok
vado alla per un attimo sto guardando
del corso di blu credendo di essere meno
male va bene abbiamo vinto bene non
delle una delle migliori hop silenzi che
abbia mai fatto anzi tutto il contrario
però va bene mettiamo in dodici una
bella finalina partite orribili perché
comunque tutto partito dalla prima che
che erano già ex a con non ci voglio
credere lega non ci credo posso vincerla
posso vincerla e del partito tutto non è
detto per niente anzi adesso mi faranno
fuori ma è partito tutto dal fatto che
ora prendere l'acqua c'è se io lasciavo
l'acqua di là cioè scusatemi se io stavo
un secondo in più di là ea persa c'è poi
pensate che che che destino in farmi
tanto per gli altri
in genere con me la porto a casa quasi
sempre quindi teoricamente dormire
teoricamente dovrebbe vincerla poi non
lo so no no no perché sono stupido ma
perché no niente niente niente poco
cadeau km orribile orribile orribile
perché correte tutti fatevi la vita bene
bene molto bene per adesso tutto ok
onesto onesto
beh allora ho recuperato un po adesso è
perché la gente è caduta di sotto però
questo quando vide le semi rocca e per
sete dall'uomo piano piano zio ti prego
vai piano siamo in due
che ti fotte siamo contro ma in questo
momento siamo sul piano grafico bene
anche attento al piano va bene se mi
sono caduto di mostrarci le ok gatto
maledetto vuoi stare zitto e fermo
titolo 6 perché non parli niente ragazzi
partita veramente come onesta ma
brunetta è una brutta forte forse riesco
a recuperare un po di giallo ma neanche
tanto miconi l'ha buttato subito ma devo
giocare bene qua ragazzi perché se fossi
in tre servizi intera che non li vedo
non solo le sono un sacco di strada
l'abbiamo perso tutto
come ho fatto a vincere questa partita
come cioè sono partito che stavo
prendendo l'acqua meno male che mi è
uscita ex come alla fine perché si
riusciva colmata in ciao con tutto
alcuno che ha avuto all'inizio figurati
se mi faceva partire prima però meno
male che uscita ex lo era l'unica dove
potevo vincerla perché ho jump su dow
anche effettivamente guarda come vi
rende i capelli soggiorno c'è veramente
una pazzia proprio la grasta roba 14 non
c'è neanche la finale forse ammette
jobso dow oppure non mette la finale
mettere molle che tra l'altro non faccio
una vita oppure slime nostra monica
frigo formare ragazzi sono incerto
proprio per questo motivo perché hanno
aggiunto gli ostacoli no
e da quando gli hanno aggiunti è tutto
un po più randomico quindi un po paura
però vabbè se giochiamo bene ragazzi vi
prego soprattutto voi che siete vestiti
da lupo e ancora mi chiedo come se si
fossero saluto c'era qualcuno in deep e
ti prego fai il tuo lavoro fai schifo
quello che faccio ridere perché non è
possibile è una risata sclerotica web
ok a tutte e due le palle qua sono tutte
una una palla più avanti a possiamo
spingere bravi per favore contropiede
dai cipro sono attirato chissà che
bordata almeno questa portata avanti vai
vai al momento al momento nel momento al
momento vuoi colo tiri non ce ne sono né
iraq 21 comunque siamo e ragazzi
sì porco demonio come ho detto che mi
che qualcuno la farà se no mi ammazzo la
parata qualcuno che non entrato ok
perfetto dove l'arco dio santissimo
rinvio dal fondo
tensione anche tre secondi facciali
ambito così che partita bruttissima se
posso permettermi di football brutti
partita orribile però un cambiamento va
beh non posso fare il trick di andare in
fondo perché siamo troppo poi troppo
pochi ma posso resistere
forse resistere normalmente con la mia
tattica normale non posso devo morire
1000 watt e vi joystick e datemi la
patente per favore io no io non posso
fare questa vita ragazzi non mi posso
[ __ ] da solo su hexagon sono caduto
oggi proprio sulle mani di burro anche
prima nella prima prima pratica ho fatto
una cagata su una sopra l'altra ma va
beh non so quanti sono sopra perché
siamo veramente voti ragazzi summit è
uno è già accaduto nell'ultima che era
stato notato quindi tre sono sotto
quattro sono sotto siamo io e un altro
sul viola non lo vedo ma prego
siamo in due sul mio ragazzi attenzione
non vendo l'altro ragazzo ne siano
proprio caduto annunciando dove sia
l'alto avevano nel giallo di cento
1 ward cavata alla gara sto tenendo come
se niente fosse veramente ne mancano
quasi 33 da elimina ragazzi siamo ancora
in quattro in totale 3 da eliminare
sono l'unico sul giallo perché non so se
c'è qualcuno finale credo di sì perché
ce ne sono troppo poco sotto ce n'è uno
solo
qui c'è troppa gente in alto ragazzi
devo resistere
il mio obiettivo adesso è resistere
perché quelli in alto hanno troppa
piattaforma e se non resisto qua ho
perso ok uno è caduto sono caduti tutti
quanti ok sono uno dei due più in alto
lo lascia un sacco di pattern però
maledizione come faccio dovresti starete
possibile qua ragazzo è l'unica a
resistere il più possibile qua ti prego
hd sta cadendo colorista che adesso
oddio non so chi ha più pattern tranne
lui credo lui
di soldi ne ha un sacco lui ragazzo la
famiglia non ha veramente un sacco lui
speriamo che caschi non ci sono lui e
ragazzi sono i due sono in due lingue
sono i due li si mangia da soli si
mangia da soli se faccia da ciò di cui 2
ti prego legge fatta banca e cadono
si sono mangiati l'asta meno male meno
male perché avevano tipo da solo aveva
molta più strada di me meno male che se
la sono mangiata in due perché se no non
dico che avrei perso perché magari avrei
vinto uguale ma sarebbe stata molto più
difficile meno male
due vittorie di oggi ce l'abbiamo sono
soddisfatto anche oggi a fango mamma mia
ragazzi che parcheggerà io non posso
veramente sfumare così tu guarda ora con
ritiro si riduce cappelletto iorio ma
nel frattempo ragazzi in vi ringrazio
per aver visto il video vi ricordo che
manca pochissimo alla nuova season
quando siamo al nuovo sito i ragazzi
farò una live pomeridiana sul canale e
siate c tutti direi che per oggi basta
però che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi cosa è
un bel mi piace anche a venezia dove per
iniziare se non saresti studenti e
ragazzi civile all'opposizione bella
[Musica]